dear colleagues as announced at the
beginning of this part session our
agenda of this week is dominated by the
situation
in ukraine
today we are starting our day with the
most pressing debate on eu-russia
relations european security and russians
military threat against ukraine amidst
intense
international diplomatic exchanges to
de-escalate the situation i am pleased
uh to welcome the president of the
european council charles michelle the
president of the european commission
also lavonda lyon and the high
representative of the union for foreign
affairs and security policy joseph
borrel who are with us to discuss the
latest developments on the ground
in the wider context of european
security and eu russia relations welcome
to the plenary
on behalf of the european parliament we
have repeatedly expressed
solidarity with the people of ukraine
as they continue to face
the uncertainty over the past weeks
and fear of russian military aggression
what we are witnessing here is also a
threat to peace in europe
i want to recall that in september last
year the european parliament adopted a
resolution that called
for containing russian's influence in
the eu and its eastern neighborhood
and in december last year we also
adopted a resolution where we criticized
the actions of the russian authorities
and underlined our preparedness to agree
swiftly on further joint action
including sanctions today
just after this debate we will vote on
granting 1.2 billion euros of macro
financial assistance to ukraine and i
would like to thank the european
commission for this timely proposal to
support ukraine's financial stability
and resilience in the current difficult
circumstances
also later today the conference of
presidents will discuss the declaration
on the situation in ukraine
i would like to stress that
while we urge for a de-escalation of the
current tension between ukraine and
russia this parliament stands ready to
support
swift
forceful and concrete action in
coordination with other european
institutions
the union's unity and close cooperation
with our partners are key
for the european union to play a strong
role on the international stage and to
contribute to peace
and security
we would be interested to know how
lessons learned from the current
situation will be reflected also in the
works on the future strategic compass
for the european union
finally i would like to thank you
president michelle president van der
lyon and high representative borel for
your engagement in the intense
consultation on identifying ways to
address the situation at the eu's
eastern borders and your efforts to
uphold fundamental principles of the
existing european security architecture
so without further delay
i would like to give the floor to the
president of the european council
charles michelle for your statement
madam president of the european
parliament madam prayer of the
commission
the high representative ladies and
gentlemen dear colleagues
this week is expected to be an important
geopolitical week for the european union
we will hold
our joint summit with the african union
some 80 delegations of african
and european leaders
are arriving in brussels to negotiate a
strategic partnership between our two
continents
yet
the
extremely serious situation
in eastern europe
has trapped into all our agendas
and allow me to lay out the range of
actions
taken by the eu to deal with this crisis
in very close coordination with our
allies
and let me explain how the european
council will approach our future
decisions
whether in the short or longer term
ladies and gentlemen
russia
has undertaken an unprecedented military
installation against ukraine
the russian authorities have repeatedly
said
they have no aggressive intentions
towards this sovereign country and this
despite already annexing part of
ukrainian territory crimea in 2014
and constantly undermining ukraine's
sovereignty especially in eastern
ukraine
encircling a country
with
an extraordinary deployment of military
forces never seen before
can only be seen
as aggressive
and strengthening behavior
this escalation
not only endangers the stability and
integrity of ukraine
it also threatens peace
and security in europe
and the world's best international
system
we
the eu
nato allies member states
are working together at every level on a
daily basis consulting politically and
acting together we are working
at a level of intensity and quality that
we have not seen for years
our unity is stronger than ever
and we have adopted
a strong and clear strategy
in three areas
first
diplomacy
we have chosen to give every opportunity
to the diplomatic roots
european
and american leaders have undertaken
countless diplomatic initiatives and
missions we have activated negotiating
platforms for dialogue with russia such
as nato
the oic
or the normandy format
and i would like to commend olef schultz
and emmanuel
for the important role
we have never stopped giving priority to
diplomatic channels
even when these efforts did not seem to
produce immediate tangible results
yet
in the last two days
russia has signaled that it may be open
to diplomacy
and we urge russia
to take concrete and tangible steps
towards the escalation because this is
the condition for sincere political
dialogue we cannot eternally attempt
diplomacy on one side while the other
side is amassing troops
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much president michelle i
give the floor now to the president of
the european commission usually on the
line for her statement
thank you madam president
president michelle i representative
joseph
honorable members
the very reason why our union was
created
is to put an end
to all european wars
and so it is particularly painful for me
to address you today
as we face the largest buildup of troops
on european soil since the darkest days
of the cold war
the people of ukraine are bravely trying
to get on with their lives
but many of them keep emergency bags by
their front doors with basic clothes
and important documents in case that
they have to rush away from home
others have stockpiled food cans to
prepare for the worst
some have even set up shelters in their
basements
these are not stories from the 1940s
this is europe in 2022
and this is happening because of
deliberate policy of the of the russian
leadership
ukraine is a sovereign country
it is making its own choices
about its own future
but the kremlin doesn't like this and so
it threatens war
and this is the essence
of the current escalation
this is some something we simply cannot
accept
i think diplomacy has not yet spoken its
last words
and we saw signs of hope yesterday
but now deeds have to follow those words
in the last seven years
ukraine has suffered from the kremlin's
constant aggression
but despite that
heavy burden they have ukraine has come
such a long way
it has taken important steps to fight
corruption it has rebuilt its
infrastructure it has created new jobs
for its talented youth
and our union has accompanied them
putting together the largest support
package in our history
of course the people of ukraine know
that democracy still has some flaws and
issues to deal with it
but ukraine today
is a sovereign
more free
more strong country than in 2014
and this is precisely why the kremlin is
threatening it again
we stand firm with ukraine
the idea that the kremlin should decide
what ukrainians can or cannot desire we
simply cannot accept
and the idea of spheres of influence
are ghosts of the last century
this crisis is about ukraine yes but it
is also about much much more
it is also about what it means to be a
sovereign independent and free country
in the 21st century
it is about everyone's right to live
free from fear and it's about every
country's right to determine its own
future
and this is the message that our union
has to send to the kremlin
like everyone in this room i truly hope
that the kremlin will decide not to
unleash further violence in europe
yesterday russia was certainly sending
conflicting signals
on the one hand authorities announced
russian true pullbacks
on the other hand the duma votes for the
formal recognition of donetsk and
luhansk as independent republics
but i still strongly believe in
diplomacy
it is good to hear yesterday's
commitment to the minsk agreement
president macro and chancellor schultz
have traveled to kiev and moscow
several others are also speaking to both
sides
i'm constantly exchanging
with all of them as well as president
biden prime minister trudeau prime
minister johnson i must really say the
transatlantic community has for a long
time not been so united
let me just mention one recent episode
earlier this month
russian foreign minister lavrov
wrote 36 letters to each and every
member state of the european union and
nato ally with a series of demands
he received two
letters in response
one from joseph burrell
on the behalf of the european union and
one from jens stoltenberg
on behalf of nato
the european union and its transatlantic
partners are united in this crisis
and our call to russia is crystal clear
do not choose war
a path of cooperation between russia and
us is still possible
but let's stay vigilant
despite yesterday's news
nato has not yet seen signs of any
russian troop reduction
and should the kremlin choose violence
against ukraine our response
will be strong and united
the european commission and the eas
working closely have been working
closely with all member states to
prepare a robust and comprehensive
package
of potential sanctions
and we have worked in very close
coordination with our friends from the
united kingdom the united states and
canada and let me say in that in these
weeks we have built a unity of purpose
that is truly remarkable both within the
european union and with our partners
in case of a russian aggression
europe's reaction will be swift and
robust
and we're not just talking about
freezing assets and banning travel for
russian individuals
russia's strategic interest is to
diversify its economy its one-sided
economy and to close its current gaps
but for this
they need technologies in which we have
a global leadership
high-tech components of which russia is
almost entirely dependent on us
so our sanctions can bite very hard
and the kremlin knows this as well
and on another topic we are also ready
in case that the russian leadership
decides to weaponize the energy issue
you know we see at a time of high demand
that gas problem is restricting its gas
supplies to europe we see a 10 years low
in storage by gas crumb
we see no sales on the stock market spot
market this is a strange behavior for a
company that in times of skyrocketing
demand and prices they are not trying to
maximize their profits
and this behavior has already damaged
russia's credibility as a reliable
energy supplier
we are since weeks and talks with a
number of countries that are ready to
step up their exports of liquefied
natural gas to the european union
and this resulted now in january in
record deliveries of lng gas more than
120 vessels that is the equivalent of 10
10 billion cubic meters of lng
and on top we've done our homework
since the annexation of crimea we have
increased the number of lng terminals in
the european union we have reinforced
our pan-european
pipeline and electricity interconnector
network
and the good part in this story is that
these investments and infrastructure we
have done
will in future be the backbone for the
possibility to supply with green
hydrogen so they are future proof
and now we have during the last weeks
looked into all possible disruption
scenarios in case russia decides to
partially or completely disrupt gas
supplies to the european union
and i can say today
that our models show with all the
measures we have taken
that we are now on the safe side for
this winter
on top of this
we have also developed with a number of
member states a new set of emergency
measures which we could trigger in case
of complete disruptions
but one of the main lessons we have
already learned from this crisis
honorable members is
that we must diversify our energy
sources and we must get rid of the
dependency of russian gas we must
heavily invest in renewables
our alternative are renewables because
though renewables are clean and good for
the climate but they are also homegrown
and good for our independence that's why
our future lies
honorable members this is a crisis that
has been created by moscow
we have not chosen confrontation
we are hoping for the best
but we are prepared for the worst
we now have two distinct futures ahead
of us
in one
the kremlin decides to wage war against
ukraine
with massive human costs something we
thought we had left behind after the
tragedies of the 20th century
moscow's relation with us would be
severely damaged tough sanctions would
kick in with dire consequences on the
russian economy and its prospect of
modernization
but another future is possible
a future in which russia and europe
cooperate on their share interests
a future where free countries work
together in peace
a future of prosperity
built on the respect of the fundamental
principles
that are enshrined in the un charter and
in the european security architecture
since the helsinki final act
this is my aspiration and i'm sure
the russian people
share this aspiration too
it's now up to the kremlin to decide
but whatever path they decide to take
we will stand our ground
europe will be united
on the side of ukraine on the side of
peace
and on the side of europe's people
long-lived europe thank you
thank you
very much
president von der lion i invite now high
representative joseph burrell to take
the floor
a
presidente
is
allow me to
talk about a little bit
which has been the role of european
diplomacy in these events
it has been said that europe was missing
in action
we have heard
that the european is missing in actions
and things are happening without
our presence without a participation
led by united states who are negotiating
over our head
i think that we have to respond to this
criticism
which seems at all unfunded by several
reasons
first because the member states of the
union have consistently debating the
issue of security in europe and ukraine
and we have achieved a remarkable unity
because every member states france and
germany have taken a number of political
initiatives
to promote a peaceful settlement of the
crisis
and these initiatives have been carried
in coherence
with the positions of the union
and in conditions of great transparency
and third
because russia deliberately tried to
ignore the existence of the european
union
by sending letters only to the united
states and nato in december
considering that we are completely
relevant and has nothing to say about
the security issues in europe
for moscow
the security in europe is being defined
in washington
later
when they will notice that
despite this dismissive attitude
nothing was going on
minister lavrov finally decided to send
a letter to the 27 member states
that he had enough until now
why such a new turn on the russian
position
for two reasons
first
because they realized that the european
front was not crack
and the atlantic solidarity was very
strong
so he tried to maneuver
which was to send letters to the 27
member states hoping to have 27
different answers but in this case
mr lavrov didn't succeed
because we sent him
a single letter
saving him the time to lead to read 27
letters all of them equal
just one
one letter representing the position of
the european union on behalf of the 27
member states
and this is a good example of how we
europeans we can work together
and together with our allies with the us
and other like-minded countries with
which we have had a continuous and very
much positive coordination so we have
been present participating
on the negotiations if we can call them
negotiations at least conversations
until now
so what we can envisage next
well we don't know
nobody knows they are encouraging signs
but also
very much worth some events
like devoting to douma asking putin
to recognize
the independency of the two let's say
republic and the donbass
we don't know what putin is going to do
but what is clear that we have to
continue offering both things at the
same time
the will to negotiate
be ready to participate in talks because
yes russia has also security concerns
that has to be taken into consideration
and on the other hand to prepare our
capacity to respond
our dissuasion tools
sanctions as a panel of the commission
and the president of the council has
been referring to
on that we have been working and on that
we are ready to act
but
most of all we are ready to continue
negotiations talk in order to look for a
diplomatic solution to the worst crisis
that europe is living since the end of
the cold war
and i repeat again this crisis not only
affects ukrainians not only the
europeans
it's affect the direction of humankind
thank you very much
thank you
very much to the high represent